[Música]
você acha que o mundo seria um lugar
melhor hino que vem na próxima década
podemos acabar com a fome alcançar a
igualdade de gênero ou controlar as
mudanças climáticas
tudo isso nos próximos 15 anos Bom
segundo os governantes do nosso planeta
sim nós podemos
Esse foi o começo da apresentação de
Michael Green no TED Talks da Inglaterra
de 2015 mesmo ano em que foram
desenvolvidos os 17 objetivos de
desenvolvimento sustentável
objetivos esses que visam a melhora do
nosso planeta como um todo
depois de seis anos desde a criação da
agenda 2030 e falta números de 9 anos
para o cumprimento do prazo do sudestes
você sabe ou sequer soube o que são eles
uso de s ou objetivos de desenvolvimento
sustentável são 17 objetivos
desenvolvidos pela ONU no ano de 2015
com o objetivo de melhorar o nosso
planeta como um todo são metais
extremamente oficiosas já que a ideia é
melhorar a média do índice de
desenvolvimento humano de 61 para 75 em
apenas 15 anos
no entanto a falta de conhecimento a
respeito desses o desses causa um atraso
no cumprimento das metas
bom
Como vocês podem ver nós temos o dessas
que atuam em áreas diferentes temos
aqueles que atuam no meio ambiente do
nosso planeta que são esses que vocês
podem ver na parte debaixo da nossa
pirâmide temos aqueles que atuam
diretamente na sociedade são os que
estão no meio
e outros que são um pouco mais acima que
atuam na nossa economia Global
Mas se nós observamos bem temos um
último objetivo bem no topo dessa
pirâmide Esse é o objetivo de número 17
cuja a ideia é unir todos os países do
nosso planeta para que juntos possamos
alcançar todas essas metas é importante
ressaltar que por mais que esteja
apresentando para vocês uma pirâmide não
significa que a gente tem um objetivo
mais importante do que o outro não todos
são extremamente importantes
Independente de qual área eles atuam o
investimento neles nosso tempo investido
nosso dinheiro investido tudo investido
nele deve ser investido de forma igual
todos devem ser vistos como com a mesma
importância
O problema é que
nós temos o 17 objetivo certo só que
cada um tem suas metas são metas
individuais de números diferentes ou
seja dos 17 objetivos iniciais nós
caímos para 69 169 metas
é um número que inicialmente
Parece até o cansável
o problema surge quando
se observa e Analisa melhor essas metas
parece que uma coisa não foi levado em
consideração pela ONU no desenvolvimento
desses objetivos e no desenvolvimento
dessas metas
as intersecções entre elas
metas diferentes podem interferir umas
às outras ou seja um exemplo eu estou
fazendo alguma coisa um projeto uma ação
e estou focando em uma dessas metas só
que coincidente mente ela interfere
positivamente em outra ou seja no geral
isso é bom ser positivo eu consegui por
meio de uma meta alcançar a outra no
entanto da mesma forma que temos
intersecções positivas podemos ter
intersecções neutras onde não temos
nenhuma mudança mas também intersecções
prejudiciais
E aí que surge o nosso problema
você deve tá olhando para mim agora e
pensando pô ferrou porque se eu trouxer
vocês De Volta Para o esquema que eu
mostrei antes nós tínhamos 17 objetivos
que se tornaram 169 metas e se levarmos
em consideração apenas os 17 objetivos
de maneira geral temos
272 intersecções
mas se levarmos cada meta em
consideração teremos um total de mais de
28 mil
intersecções a serem consideradas
por favor não entre em Pânico
eu tive o mesmo questionamento em 2019
Será que é possível
resolver e melhorar evitar essas
intersecções prejudiciais
bom conversando com colegas e com o meu
orientador e o num primeiro momento
pensei ferrou não tenho que fazer é
impossível mas foi por conta desse meu
pessimismo
que eu comecei a refletir
como é que um jovem
de ensino médio como eu
pode ajudar não Sinceramente resolver
mas colaborar para que essas metas
possam ser alcançadas e junto disso eu
lembrei de uma frase que era muito dita
pelo meu orientador
o pensar global e agir local você sabe
já tinha escutado essa frase Ela foi
dita pelo sociólogo alemão Ulrich Beck
ou de ele trazer as ideia de você ter
ideias de maneira Global pensar
globalmente mas as suas ações não
deveriam começar de maneira global e sim
local focar na sua casa no seu bairro na
sua escola para que assim você pudesse
começar a fazer a sua diferença
a partir disso e de boas reflexões e
conversas com os meus colegas nós
achamos uma possível solução para isso
nós desenvolvemos um projeto que buscava
solucionais
então eu vou projeto como exemplo mas
quero que vocês prestem bastante atenção
nisso pensa em um projeto social ou em
alguma ação que você participa ou
conhece eu vou usar de exemplo o history
Blocks um projeto social desenvolvido
pela Unesco com o objetivo de
Reconstruir o monumentos históricos
dentro do ambiente do Minecraft
agora analise este projeto Leiam
entendam
e Então usa 10 que apresentei para vocês
agora junto hein eles o que eu quero
dizer com isso analise veja o que o seu
projeto tem como objetivo e o que os
buscam o que cada objetivo que cada meta
está buscando
certo então seguimos para a etapa de
comparação de análise inicialmente
descobrimos quais metas estão sendo
trabalhadas pelo nosso projeto aqui por
exemplo Essas são as metas que nós
descobrimos que eram trabalhadas pelos
blogs
e agora nós precisamos analisar cada uma
entre si para descobrir se essas
intersecções presentes são positivas
neutras ou negativas
e como vocês podem ver aqui eu trouxe um
exemplo de comparação pode ser feita
a partir disso a gente chega para uma
parte que na minha opinião é livre eu e
meus colegas fizemos de um jeito mas eu
acho que cada um pode fazer do jeito que
achar melhor do jeito que preferi porque
porque agora é a parte onde você escolhe
uma forma de agir O que você vai fazer e
como você vai fazer para aplicar essas
metas nesse projeto social que você
escolheu
no nosso caso eu e os meus colegas nós
decidimos elaborar um Canvas um
documento que trazia informações a
respeito do Hitler Box junto dos o
desses as metas que eram a trabalhar
trabalhadas e explicações a respeito
delas
esse documento nós enviamos para os 50
baixadores do Ibox São 50 professores
cada um de um país diferente espalhados
pelo mundo inteiro que aplicam o projeto
dentro da sala de aula para seus alunos
esses professores viram os documentos
leram nosso documento e nos deram
feedback
comentaram a respeito deles dele e
podemos perceber que a partir do nosso
Canvas aprendi na nossa pesquisa da
nossa análise a respeito do projeto
junto dos o desses
esses professores
receberam uma informação extremamente
importante relevante para que eles
pudessem
melhorar ou não necessariamente melhor
horário mas adicionar as suas aulas ou
seja iniciar esse processo de
cumprimento das metas essas que vocês
podem ver que são trabalhados pelos seus
blocos dentro da sala de aula
infelizmente existe um outro problema
algumas pessoas empresas escolas até
acham que trabalharam desce é
simplesmente eu pegar uma imagem de um e
desce de uma meta e pendurar na parede
mostrar uma propaganda como vocês
puderam ver não é tão simples assim
existe todo todo mais e tem que ser
feita por trás de todo um conjunto de
intersecções podem interferir nisso
mostrar uma imagem não é trabalhar 110
bom lembrando da pergunta que eu tinha
feito para mim mesmo 2019 o que um aluno
de ensino médio como eu pode fazer para
ajudar a alcançar os objetivos da Agenda
eu pude junto dos meus colegas alcançar
um reconhecimento Nacional por meio de
feiras de ciências onde nós participamos
fomos até premiados
aumentando o conhecimento a respeito dos
o desses localmente mas também recebeu
um reconhecimento internacional
por uma instituição do botão por exemplo
ou com a própria participação na world
legislação da Unesco a maior aula do
mundo
tivemos a honra de apresentar esse
projeto essa ideia essa pesquisa
para jovens do Cabo Verde
bom
levando em conta a pandemia o fato do
mundo inteiro separado o fato da gente
ter desacostumado com tudo nós podemos
perceber que chegou a hora de realizar
de recomeçar
Então eu acho que essa discussão ela não
termina aqui
o ano de 2030 já tá aqui na porta por
mais que não pareça
então a questão que fica a questão que
eu faço para vocês é
o que você pode fazer agora
obrigado
[Música]